this presentation we are going to talk
about how in genepattern office software
and uncle and software can be used in
combination to discover cellular
mechanisms and biomarkers and help
anyone non-responder datasets
just a quick legal disclaimer that the
product I'm going to show you are meant
for miscarry purposes as opposed to
diagnostic purposes
so as I mentioned in my title slide we
want to identify mechanisms action
biomarkers regulators and targets from
an anti pd-1 non-responder dataset I
want to clarify that this can be
actually done on any data sets public or
your own
alright so user can also do a lot of
things I'm going to show you with their
own data set as well in part one of the
presentation we are going to focus on
data mining we're going to do that by
using uncle line from omics walk so in
this case I'm going to introduce you to
what omics soft is and what Uncle land
is then using Uncle and software we
going to locate an N type 81
non-responder data set and later on
we're going to study some biomarkers
such as ug t 1 a 6 and a 3 and we're
going to study with biomarkers in more
details by exploring curated data from
TCGA and G Tech and then finally we are
going to associate this markers with
patient survival in part two because
should study remaining of the data set
right so in a part one I just mentioned
true genes so in part two we're going to
do data interpretation using intuitive
pathway analysis we're going to learn
about what this software is and how it
can be used to study mechanism of action
biomarkers and regulators and then we
will end with a summary
so let me talk to you a little bit about
this case 30 right so interaction
between PD 1 and PDL 1 is a very
well-known immune checkpoint and that's
why there are so many drugs that are
designed to block this interaction one
of the drugs is nivel you map offered by
BMS this is also known as obvio so if
you watch TV you might have instant
commercial for octavo it blocks PD 1 it
is used in indication such as melanoma
non-small cell lung carcinoma renal cell
carcinoma and others now the problem is
many PDL 1 expressing tumors they don't
respond to therapy
our whole question is why and as I
mentioned we want to start by maybe
locating an interesting data set to say
you were to do this on your own then
typically what you do is you would go to
a public domain so you usually go into
different sources are listed over here
such as TCGA geo and so on and then you
will be locating interesting data set or
data sets right now if you want to
thoroughly study this data set then
you'll be first of all downloading that
if it is an NGS data set then you will
be cusing it as well so you'll be
checking like you know what is the
quality of reads and such afterwards
you'll be processing this data set
through secondary analysis pipeline so
again if it's an NGS data set that if
RIT you will be mapping reads to the
reference and you'll be Q seeing like
you know okay how many these are map
which the communities are not map and
then finally you will do things such as
quantify gene and transcript expression
and then calculate differential
expression between groups of your
interest right so you might be comparing
non-responder versus responders which is
what we are going to do or you might be
comparing disease versus normal
treatment one versus treatment - right
this will depend on you but basically if
you were to be dealing with public data
set you'll be doing all of this right
now imagine you're really doing the same
thing with hundreds if not thousands of
public data set right because you want
to generate a powerful hypothesis or you
want to generate a powerful discovery
you would have to repeat this process
for hundreds if not thousands of data
set and in addition to that you would
have to curate metadata for all of this
data so each data set will have
description
what tissue is it coming from what cell
line is coming from if it's coming from
some sort of treatment or the drug
concentration what was the time for the
treatment its patient data or is it in
vitro data right so you'll be curating
all of this metadata as well
fortunately our omics off team has
already done all of this so they have
curated data from many different public
sources that are listed on the right
hand side such as TCGA which stands for
the Cancer Genome Atlas this has a lot
of tumor tissue information as well as
normal tissue information and normal
tissue will be adjacent to the tumor geo
which has a lot of public datasets
same with array expressed ccle which has
cancer cell line information gtex
which has information for normal tissue
right so our team has gone through all
of these different public sources on the
left-hand side and curated a lot of data
and metadata furthermore all of this
expression data from public sources is
passed to the same pipeline so user can
do cross project and cross the cross
collection comparison
all of this is stored in omec soft lands
database which is the image on the lower
right corner and this database is
maintained and updated regularly so let
me tell you just a little bit more about
this database user can have access to
this database through a couple of
different products I have listed three
of the frauds over here one is on :
which has oncology data again from
sources such as TCGA geo ccle and others
disease plan which has non oncology data
so this would be data relevant to
cardiovascular disease metabolic
diseases neurological diseases and
others and then finally genetics land
which has a lot of variant information
so this can be germline variants this
can be things like Jeeva and p-box
Association studies reference collection
and more and if you go to our website we
have greater description for all of this
products and the cool part is user can
also upload their own data have it
processed to the same pipeline and then
query across user data and public data
using this lens alright so in our case
because we are interested in anti pd-1
or responder we are going to focus more
on on kolaks
so first question we can ask is you want
to discover mechanism action target
market etc but first of all how can we
locate an interesting data set using the
software so in this case what we are
doing is they're opening up geo
collection within the software I have a
screen shot on the lower right corner
right and you can see this is a
point-and-click software right so it has
a GUI so you don't really need command
line knowledge but for those of you who
like to work with come online we also
offer API and again what we have done is
open up geo collection and at this point
user can search by variety of keywords
such as disease name drug names etc now
what we are interested in doing is we
want to locate a data set where we have
responders and non-responders for anti
pd-1 therapy right so we are actually
looking for patient data so in the
screenshot on my right hand side you see
I have selected subject treatment take
filter so within software you can
specify that you're interested in
patient data as opposed to say in-vitro
data so subject treatment will focus
more on patient data and over here when
you click on it you see an screen
opening up where I'm typing nivel you
map as soon as I start typing Nawal you
map some hits come up so I'm selecting
those hit and then pressing ok so when I
press ok what the software will do is it
will pull up all the patient studies
relevant to now volume map right and
those studies are listed in the bottom
table now one of the great thing is our
team has curated metadata so you can
actually learn more about this study by
simply studying the table but you can
see there are some also links as well so
reading the links you can read more
about this study and decide which
studies you want to focus on so in my
case I'm focusing on this study with GSA
IDT SC six seven five zero one
why this specific study well in this
study authors are working with
metastatic renal cell carcinoma patients
they are administering this patients
with novel you map the study by the way
is performed at Johns Hopkins and
afterwards patients are classified as
dis ponders and non-responders as my
response evaluation criteria in solid
tumor afterwards they extract irony and
then use microarray and Illumina chip to
perform gene expression analysis what I
have over here is just summary of
matters if you want to read about this
in more details you can of course follow
the citation at the bottom and read
about this in a lot more details
so now that we have located interesting
study the question is can we look at the
gene expression data from this study so
we can again start identifying mechanism
of action biomarkers etc within the
software using the GSE ID number that I
emphasized on previous slides you can
easily open a couple of different views
when it comes to gene expression you can
open up a table view which I'm showing
you on the right hand side where you can
have a list of genes with differential
expression in terms of block for change
p-value adjusted p-value etc or you can
also open up a wall keno plot which is
in the left hand side and walk you know
plot has a log full change on x-axis and
anti log or p-value on y-axis so using
either table or working of plot you can
study the inserter highly up and down
regulate it and are significant
so in our case we want to say start
discovering like markers and targets
right so what do we do so in this case
we can study either table of or or
volcano plot so in the table we are
doing sorry in the table and working up
what we are doing comparison of
responder versus non-responder site so
if you want to focus on genes are
upregulated and non-responders then
we'll be focusing in the upper left
corner which is what I have circle using
the red circle and when we focus on
those genes what we come across is a lot
of you gt1 a family members so if you
read the paper that I mentioned they
emphasize greatly on this you gt1 a
family members and that's why I'm going
to start discussion about them right so
one of the member they highly emphasized
on is ug 2 1 a 6 and if you read about
these members then you quickly realize
that these members are involved in
metabolic and solute transport functions
so one can even propose a hypothesis
right now that you know one of the ways
and happily one non-responders might be
resisting the therapy is you know this
genes might be detoxifying exogenous and
stress-related lipids by breaking them
down and excreta them outside of the
cells right so now we have come across
an interesting mechanism of action a
gene that can potentially serve as both
biomarker or a targetable molecule so
say you want to learn more about this
gene say you want to know how this gene
is expressed across different tumor
tissues and you also compare things like
how is it access across tumor and normal
tissue what do you do within the
software we first open up geo collection
right now we are opening up TCGA
collection the Cancer Genome Atlas and
as I mentioned TCGA collection will have
information about tumor tissue as well
as adjacent normal tissue so when we
search for this gene with a few click we
can easily open up this chart and this
chart will show you how the scene is
accessed across different carcinoma and
again I would like you guys to remember
that all of the samples are processed
using the same pipeline you know this is
something our team has done very
diligently and because of that you can
easily do comparison in terms of how
this gene is accessed across different
Sonoma so in this case you can see this
gene is clearly accessed more in renal
cell carcinoma compared to something
like AML now say you want to focus more
on renewal carcinoma because our team
has also curated metadata and introduced
filters which you can see on the left
hand side you can easily click on renal
cell carcinoma disease filter and when
you do that you remove all of the other
diseases and you only keep renal cell
carcinoma and you can see what we see is
some blue samples and green samples so
blue samples are tumor samples and green
samples are just normal samples so right
now they're in the same rule there you
want to split it into rules so
fortunately in this software you can
also help grouping options so you can
easily split that one row into two rows
where you can divide things between
tumor and normal and another thing you
can also do is turn on statistics so in
the lower right corner we have turn on
statistics so you can see at least Aug 2
1 6 there is some difference in the
sensor it's slightly more expressed in
tumor compared to normal
according to this chart and significance
wise it's more the line significant but
there's not a great difference now many
investigators will tell me that tumor is
not one thing right it has many
different stages so based on the
metadata that is curated by the team can
we split this into different stages of
tumor yes it is very easy within the
software you can subgroup things into
different stages as you can see over
here so now tumor Row is split into
stage 1 2 3 4 etc and again you know
difference wise we see some difference
but the difference is not that great I
mean there is some difference between
stage 1 & 2 2 & 3 etc but it's not that
free now keep in mind you do to one a
six it's just one of the family members
what about other family members such as
you gt1 a three so we can also search
for ugt one a three and again we see the
same pattern that like you gg1
a six you GT 1 a 3 is excess also more
in renal cell carcinoma as opposed to
say something like AML which is at the
bottom of the screen right like you did
one a six we can flip and filter and
what we see is for ug 1 a 3 this greater
different
compared to you two-to-one a six and
statistically speaking we also see more
see more significant p-value in the
lower right corner finally when we split
the tumor rule into different stages we
kind of see this increasing pattern as
we go from stage one to stage four so I
personally feel that most usually one is
a AC and six are expressed more in renal
cell carcinoma compared to other but
usually what a three might have better
application as marker based on the
charts we have seen so far now the
problem here is many people don't like
the normal tissue that they see over
here because this is adjacent normal
tissue right so many people feel that
this adjacent normal tissue may or may
not be normal so what they want to do is
they want to compare tumor tissue from
TCGA with normal tissue from gtex data
base so gtx database by the way only has
information about normal tissues right
so they want to compare tumor tissue
from TCGA and normal tissue from gtex
and again because our team has
diligently curated all of the expression
data using the same pipeline and store
that in land database you can easily
make this comparison so you can open up
what we call virtual ends right so what
your legs will be mixture of different
collections I'll just teach TCGA gtex
and so on and using that you can
generate charts like the ones I'm
showing you over here and again I want
to emphasize this is like
point-and-click software if you want
come online then you have option for
that as well but you know if you don't
help command-line experience you can
easily still like point-and-click and
generate the charts like the ones I'm
showing you over here so in this chart
what we see is we have tumour from TCGA
as the top row solid tissue normal which
is the adjacent normal tissue from TCGA
as the second row and then finally
normal tissue from G text as the third
row what you see over here is there is
not much difference in expression
between normal of TCGA and gtex but
there's greater difference in expression
between both normals and tumor from TCGA
so again market applications wise you GT
a ugt1a1 out to be a good marker because
this clear
between tumor and normal and again we
can turn on statistics in the software
in the lower right corner you can see
the p-value and it is significant for
this cross comparison across three
groups so in summary we found that you
gt1 a three and a six for most expressed
more in renal cell carcinoma compared to
other tumors but you GT one a three had
greater difference in expression between
tumor and normal tissue and this was
true both for TCGA tumor in normal and
also TCGA versus gtex tumor in normal
and then you GT one a six can potential
service marker but it has it had lesser
degree of difference now one thing I do
want to remind you is I have gone
through only one or two collections like
right like so we went through TCGA geo
but keep in mind our curators helped
curated data from many other collections
that are listed in the lower left corner
and one of them collect one of these
collections is ccle which has cancer
cell line information so say you as a
user might want to investigate this in
different cancer cell line and you will
see similar conclusions in the sense
that you didn't want a six seems to be
excess more in kidney cancer cell line
as opposed to say a cairo cancer cell
line which is one of the cell lines at
the bottom
so what else can we do using the
software the answer is you can actually
do a lot of different things but one of
the other things that many users want to
do is they want to divide the samples
based on the criteria daily size so one
of this criteria can be expression
criteria so say you wanted to divide the
samples between samples that have high
expression of you gt1 a six and low
expression of you GT one a six then you
can very easily do that in this software
using what we call custom queries all
right so you can make a custom query for
you to you want a six like I have done
and you can divide samples that have
high expression off usually one a six
versus low expression of ug one to a six
and then once you divide snappa based on
the criteria you decide you can generate
many different types of plots like
survival curves heat map and other plots
as well so in this case say you wanted
to test the value of you GT one a six as
prognostic marker then you will be maybe
looking at something like survival
curves and what you see is when you have
high expression of usually one a six
which is the blue line there is relative
core survival compared to when you have
low expression of you gt1 a six now this
is across all TCGA tumors and if we look
at the log-rank test which in which is
in the upper right corner then we can
see this is a this seems to be
significant and we can do the same thing
across renal cell carcinoma patients
right so remember in this software we
have filters right so we can filter it
for only renal cell carcinoma and again
we see the same pattern in the sense
that when you have high you gt1 a six
expression there is relatively poor
survival compared to when you have low
you gt1 a six expression though I have
to say that when I turn on the
statistics this does not turn out to be
significant nevertheless we can say that
we are seeing similar pattern and cool
thing is you don't have to stick with
one marker you can actually check this
for you for more number of markers as
well so we're here now we have two lines
first line the blue line is for samples
that have high expression of both ugt 1
8 3 and usually want a 6
the second line green line is for
samples that have low expression of ug
two and A three and a six and you can
see when you have high expression of
both of these markers a three and a six
there is relatively poor survival
compared to when you have low expression
for both of these markers and again I
want to clarify this is across all the
tumors and if you look at the p-value it
is significant
so my summary for this would be there
might be some prognostic value for this
you gt1 a timely member in the sense
that when we had high expression we saw
relatively poor survival across you know
different tumors and at least when we
filter it down to renal cell carcinoma
for usually one a six it does not turn
out to be similar it does not turn out
to be significant but we still see
similar pattern as you know we would
expect when you have high expression
there is for survival compared to when
you have low expression there is
slightly better survival the major point
I want to make is user can choose to
divide data based on the criteria
daylight right so in this case we divide
a sample based on samples that had high
expression of usually one a six versus
low expression of fugitive one a six in
your case you can use gene of your
interest so instead of fugitive on a six
you can take like say EGFR or lag or
whichever gene you like and you can say
okay device sample based on high
expression of this gene versus low
expression of this gene or device sample
based on high high expression of gene
one gene to and low low expression of
gene one scene to and you don't have to
just stick with expression markers you
can also device them both based on
histological markers so you can divide
samples their her2 positive versus hard
to negative triple negative breast
cancer versus non triple negative breast
cancer or go with mutation markers
samples are mutants for tp53 versus wild
coyote p53 the idea here is once you
divide sample based on the criterias you
like you can generate many different
types of plots that I'm showing you over
here on this slide you can generate
survival curves so we have survival
curve for tp53 mutant versus
wall type patient in the I'm sorry
usually one a six mutant versus welfare
patient on the right hand side you can
also generate heat map so we see heat
map or comparing two different
ah parentis and you can also generate
things like alternative splicing view in
genome browser which is in the lower
left corner in addition to that I have
seen people working with artistic Fusion
copy number variation mutation viral and
bacterial count using uncle and software
so now that we have gone through data
mining you know now that we look at it
and interesting and I believe a
non-responder data set we also like
studied biomarkers such as you g21 a
three and a six across T C D and D tags
and associated them with survival let's
do interpretation you know so far we
have studied just two markets there were
also other genes that were significantly
up and down regulated so now we can ask
questions you know are they connected
with mechanism action are they connected
to potential biomarkers are they can
some of them be you know interesting
regulators and targets so IP is a
software where people typically start
with a table of molecules of the
interest so this molecules can be genes
right so in our case
we had this comparisons between
non-responder and responders and we had
lists of genes that were you know
differentially regulated so you can
start with a list of genes list of
transcript list of proteins list of
metabolites list of Micra and idea here
is you have a list but you don't know
you know what different molecules and
the in that list are doing what
different genes and proteins and that
lists are doing so that's where injury
pathway analysis and its database come
into play so using this database in
Trinity pathway analysis is going to
convert this list into different visuals
around the life right right hand side so
now instead of visualizing lists you can
see what pathways this list is connected
this what biological processes this list
is connected with you could also open up
different pathways and processes and you
can see how different gene expression is
impacting different parts of the pathway
so you can study about mechanism actions
you can also study biomarkers through
creating bar charts and heat maps that
I'm showing you on the right hand side
and you can also compare mechanism
action using the heat map so let me go
into all of this in more details the key
here is user has a list you know this
can be differential gene expression
protein lists metabolite list and user
is confused like okay what is this list
related to so that's where IPA comes
into play and it will allow you to do
interpretation that I'm showing you on
the right hand side
so one of the reason IPL allows you to
do this is it is backed by this powerful
database this is what we call knowledge
based in this knowledge base we have
curation of peer review publications a
lot of this peer review publication is
manually curated by phd-level scientists
and this is updated on weekly basis so
basically we have curation of high
quality information and this is updated
as frequently as weekly basis in
addition to that we also have curation
from third-party data sources so this
will be later social status
margarett which has protein-protein
interaction clinical trials.gov which is
information about clinical trials
powerbase which has information about
micro RNA human sake which is
information about metabolite and
pathways and such right so we curate
information our team creates information
both from peer review publications and
third-party data sources and one of the
great thing is this information curation
is quite contextual so say you upload a
list of genes or you upload two genes
then IP won't just show you that gene a
is connected to gene B it will give you
the context that this connection is
actually protein-protein interaction
this was discovered in humans in
such-and-such cell line this was
discovered by co-immunoprecipitation
experiment and most importantly it will
list the source this information is
coming from this specific publication
and if you click on the hyperlink next
to the publication it will also take you
to that publication and it will show you
the pubmed page for that publication so
you can dig into it in more detail and
see if you want to trust that
information or not but he here is we
have a database where our curators are
reading through text and figures of the
paper and manually curating a lot of the
information and that's why it is of such
great quality now just to contrast this
with the other database that I mentioned
earlier on :
right so in this database our curators
are going through text and figures and
curating knowledge as I'm showing you on
the right hand side in the other
database on : database our curators are
curating actual ingest data which user
can manipulate and generate different
charts that I showed you all right so
now you
forward with IPA before I start showing
you some charts and figures and such
it's important to know some of the
legends that I'm listing over here so an
idea you're going to see many different
colors I request you to remember four of
them red green orange blue red and green
are from your data set so that other G's
are upregulated in your data set green
other genes are now regulated on your
data set and orange and blue are the
prediction IPA is making based on your
data set and information that's curated
from previous literature so for example
MSP one is colored red that means it's
up regulated in your data set so up
regulation of MSU one is leading to
increased apoptosis IPS making this
prediction based on the information that
is curated from previous literature
similarly mag is colored green so down
regulation of that seems to be leading
to decrease apoptosis so again bed is
now regulated in your data set and IPS
predicting according to previous
literature it will lead to reduce the
pop doses similarly TGF alpha is color
red that means it's up in your data set
and this is going to lead to increased
activation of erbb2 also known as her
tooth so now that we understand some of
the basic legends say you were to upload
non-responder what's this responder
compares on in IPA so differential gene
expression for non-responder versus
responders so IPA will give you a list
of passwords I'm showing you over here
and then if you go to this path which
you will quickly realize that this
pathways are cancer related or are
related to growth Pro factor
inflammation and cell cycle
all of this are cancer related as well
so basically the top boxes we see in IPA
they're all cancer related for this anti
pd-1 non-responder datasets and you can
open up pathways so in this case to
study mechanism actions we are opening
up molecular mechanisms can a molecular
mechanism of cancer pathway and you can
see pathways are nicely organized from
plasma membrane to nucleus in this case
we have plasma membrane both on top and
bottom and we are going to nucleus in
the center if we zoom in the pathway
then we can see the functional impact of
in expression on this pathway so for
example in the center of the screen you
have NBS one color red so red means is
upregulated in your data set and this
seems to lead to increase DNA repair
because DNA repair is color orange
similarly if you focus in the lower
right corner isn't that differential
gene expression is leading to increased
cell cycle and reduce apoptosis so now
what we are figuring out is differential
gene expression that is present in
non-responder versus responder is
leading to increase VNA repair to reduce
apoptosis and increase cell cycle and
this explained why non-responder might
be resisting the therapy similarly you
know if we look at the bottom part of
the pathway we see left one red red is
upregulated if you know about left one
left one is a cell survival marker right
if you did not know about it you can
easily find it out using IPS database
and what you can see that up regulation
of left one is also leading to increased
cell survival in anti PD one
non-responder so again this is another
way they might be resisting the therapy
now that we have talked about mechanism
of action
what about biomarkers what type of bomb
arc is going to discover it might be I
already mentioned one biomarker which is
left one but in IP you can turn on this
march arts and this march arts will show
you how left one is up and non-responder
which is a red bar and down in responder
which is the green bar right so again we
would expect cell survival marker left
to be up in non-responder and down in
responders and there similarly other
markers such as the ones you see on the
right hand sides it's a cdk and to see
merck three they're also all up in
non-responder and down in responder what
if you did not know what this marker
were then you can easily use Internet is
beta base and figure out what this
markers are which is what I have done
over here so you can see marker such as
CCN d2nv and left one their off cell
viability marker and they're up in
non-responder and down in responder
similarly other markers are related to
say cell proliferation such as p sent to
map tiny 30 they're also up in
non-responder and down in responder and
then finally you're like okay you're
telling me that this markers are cell
while daily tomorrow
because this martyrs are cell
proliferation markers based on what then
again in IPA you can turn on this
relationship view page which will tell
you where this information is coming
from
for example CC NB to information is
actually coming from cell cultures and
it is coming from MK and forty-five
cells as I'm showing you at the bottom
the authors have done si R any library
screening and you can actually go to the
specific publication Lister the bottom
by clicking on the hyperlink and check
out this in more details if you want to
see how they derive this information so
you can always verify information when
it comes to biomarkers many users
actually want to find Mike biomarkers
based on other criteria so some users
for example they want to find biomarkers
based on their subcellular location so
say you are looking for biomarkers in
membrane then we also have true status
bar profiler which will allow you to use
various filters and focus on biomarkers
of your choice and over here we are
discovering that me two M can be one of
the membrane biomarkers that you can
focus on in n type eighty-one
non-responders as I'm showing you over
here
now now that we have focused most on
mechanism action and biomarkers
what about regulators and targets so in
IPA we have some powerful tools such as
option analysis and causal network which
will allow you to focus on regulators
and targets using that I have discovered
over here many transcription regulators
are connected to renal cell carcinoma
and also found to be activated by IPA
and you can see them in the center of
your screen and if you're curious what
this regulators are a lot of these
regulators are again involved in
processes with this cell cycle DNA
repair and such and similarly if you
focus on a gene such as GFP t1 and smite
3 these are enzymes so if a user is
looking for targetable molecules now you
have targetable molecules IPA can easily
give you master regulators and it can
also provide you with some interesting
targets and say you wanted to study this
target in more detail so say you wanted
to study GFP t1 in more detail you can
actually open up the network view and
you can easily see how GFP t1 is
connected to renal cell carcinoma so it
seems that GFP t1 is activating tgf-beta
1 make and tp53 and this seems to be
leading to increase renal cell carcinoma
phenotypes so while we were looking for
interesting target we can also actually
dive into mechanism action and we can
see how activation of GFP t1 is leading
to activation of now in regulators and
how that is leading to increase you know
cell carcinoma phenotypes in n type A t1
non-responders and then finally for
those of you who might be interested in
drugs targeting different genes on this
network in IP n you can easily figure
out like you know which drugs can target
[ __ ] in so over here I have a drug
targeting tgf-beta 1 and you can find
out additional information about drugs
like if this drug this drug an agonist
antagonist what clinical trials is this
drug involved in so in the table you can
see this drug is involved in different
phase 1 phase 2 clinical trials what is
it it's an immunomodulator what does it
bind to it binds to different members of
tgf-beta 1 so what here I have just
turned on one drug
honestly you can turn on drugs for many
of the factors that you see on this
network over here right so again to
summarize we have looked at like one of
the mechanisms action example we have
looked at some biomarker example and we
have also looked at a regulator example
but so far we've been studying one thing
at a time right so we've been studying
like one mechanism action at a time
using a pathway we've been studying one
biomarker at a time and we've been
studying like one you know regular time
when we look at the network what is you
wanted to do comparison across multiple
networks multiple regulators in IPA you
can turn on this heat map and using this
heat maps you can compare multiple
groups right so over here what I have to
lie PA is show me only cancer pathways
and show me how they are differentially
activated between non-responder and
responder data sets so in one problem I
have non-responder which is the orange
color and other column I have responder
which is the blue column and orange and
blue again are predictions made by IPA
and you can see a lot of these cancer
pathways are on in non-responders and
off in responder so for those of you
again who are looking for mechanism of
action you can kind of see how different
cancer related pathways are on in non
responders and this can be one of the
ways non responders are resisting the
therapy furthermore if we dive deeper
into the pathway we can see the specific
like for example if we dive in asset
il-7 signaling pathway then we can kind
of see CC and e3 is upregulated and that
is leading to proliferation of cells in
non-responder similarly other genes up
and down regulation seems to be leading
to reduce apoptosis and altered
metabolism in terms of like increased
glucose uptake so in terms of mechanism
of action and generating hypotheses in
addition to looking at the vista heat
map you can also turn on networks and
this networks will give you greater
insight
so let's take it a step further so so
far we've been comparing only two groups
from the data set that we are studying
which is the anti pity one non-responder
data set but there are other data sets
that are out there in TCGA and geo that
have to do with renal cell carcinoma so
now the question is can we compare the
data set we are studying with public
data set from TCGA NGO and see if the
mechanism of action is similar or
different across this different renal
cell carcinoma data set and other thing
we can also ask is you know can
disruption of different protein lead to
similar phenotype when we do this
comparison so as I mentioned earlier on
when I was covering on colon from omics
Hawk is in land you know our curators
have reprocessed all of the expression
data using the same pipeline and what
our IPA team has done is they have
uploaded many of this comparison in IPA
and then run core analysis on it and now
every single time you upload any data
set or any comparison IPA and by
comparison I'm talking about like
non-responder versus responder
comparison anytime you upload such
comparisons your comparison is
automatically compared to other
comparisons and this other comparison
can be your own comparison or they can
be also public comparison so again in
simpler words your IPA analysis is
compared with your other IP analysis so
if you have treatment one it will be
compared to your treatment two three
four and it is also compared to public
analysis of different data sets so in
this case we are going to again compare
and type anyone non-responder data set
with a public renal cell carcinoma data
sets so for this we have a heat map and
in this heat map the left-hand most
column is more responder versus
responder comparison which we have been
focusing on so far and it is being
compared to different renal cell
carcinoma data set from public domain
and you can see we actually come up with
some very interesting comparison in the
sense that some of the data sets on the
right hand side that are in the bigger
square these are the data set where
authors are comparing disease and
disease renal cell carcinoma tissue
versus normal renal cell carcinoma
tissue
and you can see the mechanism of action
we see in our renal cell carcinoma
dataset is similar to what we see in
this other public renal cell carcinoma
dataset and I don't have it on this
slide but the second-to-last dataset is
actually very interesting data set where
they use humanized mouse model and you
know that like shows similar behavior as
like human data sets and then in the
center you know I have also circled like
two columns and at the bottom I have
labeled M Burke 3 and II past one so
birth tree is a protein that's involved
in processes such as apoptosis invasion
cell cycle cells cell cycle and so on
and in class one has been shown to be
one of the anti tumor proteins in the
past and idea here is the comparison
you're seeing in the center is mutant
versus wild type for these genes so you
can imagine if you were to produce
mutation in a gene that is involved in
apoptosis cell cycle or in tumor
suppression you might get a profile that
is more similar to tumor and that's
exactly what we see in that Center right
so my bigger conclusion on this slide
would be that mechanism of action that
we see on in non-responder is also on in
other denote cell carcinoma data set
from public domain and then in terms of
which data set is coming from which
study you can easily click on the title
and you can find out more about the
study by looking at the table within the
software so this table will give you a
link to the study so you can go on that
link and read more about it but in
addition it will give you information
such as if the authors are using
microarray or RN C or what type of
tissue they're using what type of cell
line they're using what exactly are they
comparing what type of statistical test
they're doing all of this is easily
visible within the software by simply
clicking on the title now
using heat map if you want to study
mechanism or action in more detail so
for example if you come across
interesting regulators at the cd44 OSM
and you wanted to know how this
regulators are connected to tumor
Genesis of tissue you can easily click
on the squares next to them and you can
open up that network and then later
you can connect that network to
emergents the tissue which I have done
on the right hand side so now you're not
just saying that mechanism of action is
similar we can say the mechanism action
that is leading to two emergencies of
tissue is similar between an type in t1
non-responder and other renal cell
carcinoma data set and then finally I
want to make a distinction over here
many times people can confuse this heat
map with gene expression heat map so
keep in mind the heat map that I have on
the left hand side which has orange
color this is not a gene expression heat
map in this if map what IP is doing is
based on your gene expression data set
it is determining what factors and what
path they should be on or off right so
it determined that OS m should be on and
it has colored a orange but now you're
wondering like why OS m is turned on you
can also generate another heat map in
IPA which I'm showing you on the right
hand side so the gene heat map sorry
heat map on the right hand side is the
gene expression heat map and this gene
expression heat map shows why oh if M is
on because many of the downstream
factors of OS m are also up regulated
and that's why for M is on so this is a
very important distinction the heat map
on the left hand side is activity heat
map the heat map on the right side right
hand side is gene expression heat map
and by looking at gene expression heat
map we can also discover other
biomarkers there on not only in
non-responder but also in many of the
public datasets that we see on the right
hand side so instantly what we did is we
learn the mechanism of action by looking
at both pathways and networks so if you
remember we looked at molecular
mechanism of cancer pathways and we
learned how differentials in gene
expression was leading to increased DNA
repair reduce apoptosis and increased
cell cycle and we also looked at
interesting networks that is GFP T 1
Network where we saw increase in tj1
activity also increase in tp53 activity
and how that was leading to increased
renal cell carcinoma phenotype in
addition to that we also studied some
biomarkers it is left 1 C C and E 2 and
others which are showed both as bar
chart in the lower left
the screen and gene expression heat map
and then finally we also compare
mechanism action between data set of our
interest which is a non respondent data
set with public data set and this is the
heat map that has orange color at the
bottom right now what I did not go over
is the scenario where user does not have
data set so keeping this study in mind
to your user you don't know anything
about you gt1 a six which is what we
studied earlier on and you're like okay
how is you gt1 a six connected to renal
cell carcinoma even without data set you
can generate the network I'm showing you
on the right hand side where you just
simply search for usually one a six in
the search bar grow a network out of it
and connect it to renal cell carcinoma
and this is how you can easily figure
out that you gt1 a six can interact with
other family members such as you gt1 a
three a seven as well as other genes
that is androgen receptor and this is
how it can make connection to renal cell
carcinoma right so idea here is the
software I'm showing you you don't need
to have a data set to use them even
without data set you can generate
network and using those networks you can
generate hypotheses designed downstream
experiments and so on
so my overall summary would be we looked
at two different software and two
different databases so one software was
uncle and from omics walks and other
software was in journey pathway analysis
to contrast the database is backing this
to software on colons database has
curation of actual NGS data which is
reprocessed using the same pipeline and
user can manipulate this data to
generate expression charts volcano plot
provoker heat map that I'm showing you
in the upper right hand corner as
opposed to that injury pathway analysis
has a different type of database
ingenuity package analysis database user
employee curators are reading through
text and figures of journal articles and
creating information right so it might
have NGS information but then in
addition to that you would have
information about like western blots and
so on so in in unities knowledgebase
people are curating information from
text and figures as opposed to that in
aqua lines knowledge base
we are curating actual and just data and
that's why this two databases they are
so complementary to each other and then
can be used in combination to do many
different types of discovery so I
already mentioned discoveries by uncle
and database now for internet database
we did discovery in terms of we looked
into the mechanism action we looked at
biomarkers we also compared our analysis
with public analysis so using this to
database and software in combination you
can actually do variety of discoveries
and I have only outlined some of them in
my presentation today